la rentrée parlementaire ce sera donc le
11 septembre une rentrée qui a été
avancé de deux semaines plusieurs
dossiers ce sera votre première rentrée
en tout cas comment vous vivez cet
instant vous avez déjà pris possession
un petit peu des lieux de l'assemblée
vous étiez rendu tout à fait je fais ma
rentrée en fête le 23 juillet comme tous
les suppléants des députés qui ont été
nommés ministres
donc j'ai siégé huit jours puisque la
session s'est terminée le 31 juillet
donc ma vraie rentrée sera sera mardi
prochain quoi voilà il ya toujours cette
émotion c'est un moment particulier
vient de subversion politique
bien sûr c'est un moment d'émotion c'est
un honneur qui est fait de siéger au
palais beau bourg de représenter la
nation dont c'est un honneur que que nos
concitoyens nos fonds de de les
représenter beaucoup d'émotion quand on
pénètre dans l'hémicycle et puis la
conscience du travail accompli puisqu'on
a on est là aussi pour est d'abord et
avant tout pour défendre défendre nos
concitoyens leur apporter un mieux on
sait qu'il ya des problèmes d'emploi on
voit sur ces images justement ça nous
allait pouvoir cette semaine à
l'assemblée on voit pas déterminé
lorsque vous arrivez à l'assemblée
justement est-ce que vous est-ce que sur
place lorsque vous siégez vous posez la
question clairement vous êtes libre de
vos choix parce que vous êtes le
suppléant benoît hamon est ce que benoît
hamon vous dit comment voter comment ça
fonctionne
oui certaines lignes et vous sur la même
que lui commence à nous de travailler
avec lui pour écouter je suis
effectivement sur sur la même ligne
politique que lui je suis à la fois
engagé au parti socialiste comme lui
puis j'ai effectivement sa sensibilité
on va dire politique au sein du parti
socialiste on est plutôt sur la gauche
du parti socialiste a fait ce n'est pas
vous vous inscrivez dans la même tout à
fond mais ce n'est pas tout à fait un
hasard s'il m'a demandé ça m'a proposé
d'être dès de son suppléant il ya une
cohérence dans tout ça ceci dit il ya
aucun moment évidemment une meute et les
folles où vient me voir mais il faut que
tu vois comme ça il me laisse une totale
total totale liberté dans
dans mon vote quoi il n'y a pas besoin
de me renvoyer les oukases ou des
désordres voilà de la même façon que
j'ai recruté et que je recrute mes
collaborateurs j'ai vraiment une totale
liberté de choix et d'agir il ya une
relation
je crois pouvoir le dire entre benoît
hamon et moi de grande confiance
vous avez créé un groupe ou un mouvement
en tout cas un monde d'avancé tout à
fait qui existe déjà depuis depuis
plusieurs années au sein du parti
socialiste benoît hamon mais le en est
le responsable
voilà c'est en faites partie vous
l'avait rejoint tout à fait oui tout à
fait c'est une sensibilité politique qui
dans la fidélité la loyauté à françois
hollande
évidemment et au gouvernement et à
l'action du gouvernement fait entendre
une certaine sensibilité en particulier
sur sur l'europe
voilà vous savez employer les mots de
fidélité de loyauté c'est peut-être ce
qui vous caractérise parce que là c'est
benoît hamon dont vous le remplacer vous
avez pris également le poste de
conseiller général donc dans le
département des yvelines vous avez été
élu sur votre nous on vous avait succédé
à l'eau de vie et qui vous avez appuyé
pendant cette campagne
oui vous aviez été également son adjoint
ensuite devenu met donc maire adjoint de
sa vie commune après avoir été brûlé à
son cabinet fidélité loyauté c'est les
clés de la réussite
oh oui je crois en politique c'est sens
il
jamais oublier perdre de vue d'où l'on
vient effectivement vous savez un
parcours politique c'est fait de
rencontres moi je sais gré à benoît
hamon par exemple de m'avoir proposé
d'être suppléant un donc je le lobby pas
et je ne l'oublierai pas oui il faut
savoir d'où l'on vient
alors évidemment la loi sur le cumul des
mandats me contre 1 d'ores et déjà
fidèle et loyal
vous avez obtenu beaucoup de postes
puisque la poste de député vous êtes
conseiller général vous êtes adjoint
vous voyez donc dû renoncer au poste de
maire-adjoint
voilà j'ai dû me conformer à la loi et
qui m'a qui m'a contraint à abandonner
un mandat local
est-ce qu'il faut encore durcir cette
loi parce que ça aussi ça fait partie
des discussions des réformes qui
pourraient avoir lieu est ce qu'il faut
durcir cette loi son cumul des mandats
un seul poste seulement conseiller
général seulement débuté par exemple oui
moi je me conforme et je me suis
conformé précisément et je suis dans le
sillage précisément de ce que françois
hollande a dit devant les français un
des engagements très clairs de françois
hollande pendant sa campagne du vote des
militants socialistes également qui est
de dire un député ou un sénateur
parlementaire ne doit pas participer à
un exécutif local
il peut être conseillé municipal et
député conseiller général et député
conseiller régional et député mais ne
pas être maire et député adjoint au
maire aux maires et députés et leur
président d'un conseil général et député
pourquoi parce que les gens et à juste
titre nos concitoyens ne comprennent
plus est ce qu'il faut pouvoir durcir
justement si vous qu'il faudrait pas
choisir ça serait l'élu cité est ce que
la loi n'existe pas la loi n'existe pas
vous avez contre vous êtes conformer à
la loi et encore heureux j'ai envie de
dire mais ce qu'il faut encore aller
plus loin quel est votre sentiment
je ne suis pas en revanche pour le
mandat unique je ne suis pas pour le
mandat unique
je pense que le député le parlementaire
le député ou sénateur doit avoir un
ancrage local donc avoir doit avoir un
mandat local mais ne pas participer à un
exécutif parce qu'il ne peut pas tout
faire on ne peut pas décemment bien
faire son travail en étant maire et
député ou maire et sénateur ce n'est pas
vrai et les gens me conseillait
général et député c'est compatible wii
parce qu'on n'est pas dans un exécutif
si vous voulez je suis conseiller
général d'opposition
je n'ai pas de délégation de compétence
c'est à dire que je ne dirige pas la
collectivité c'est bien là le curseur
c'est bien là la différence
ou alors on était sur un point très
précieux de politique et de différents
cumul des mandats en regardant un petit
peu votre votre parcours on va tout de
même s'intéresser à ces différentes
réformes et qui vont intervenir durant
les prochains mois
il ya beaucoup d'attentes autour de ces
réformes oui on n'a jamais vu un
président en exercice après une
alternance est non aussi bas dans les
sondages
oui ça vous inquiète pas non est sans
doute parti socialiste va être à la
hauteur
oui le parti socialiste sera à la
hauteur à majorité de gauche à la
hauteur les sondages ne m'inquiète pas
parce que vous savez les sondages ça va
ça vient
si vous regardez les manchettes des
journaux et des hebdomadaires
cette semaine c'est totalement excessif
donc je pense qu'il ya des attentes
légitimes de nos concitoyens et et la
majorité de gauche va s'y atteler
effectivement va répondre à ses attentes
mais honnêtement peut-on décemment en
trois mois juger de l'action d'un
gouvernement et d'un chef de l'état je
le pense passer ça me semble être
vraiment un petit peu tout petit peu
rapide
entre temps la l'emportera ce jeu
augmente encore et toujours on va en
parler spécifiquement dans les yvelines
tout à l'heure lors de la chronique
aequo avec alice gastines mais pour
autant est-ce que les mesures qui vont
être prises très rapidement c'est les
premiers points qui seront abordés par
la lame la session parlementaire ça va
changer quelque chose là l'impact va
être immédiat sur l'emploi je pense
qu'il y aura un impact intéressant vous
savez les emplois d'avenir c'est 150
mille emplois les contrats de génération
dont on parlera un petit peu plus tard
durant la session parlementaire 65 cents
mille cinq cent mille emplois
il y aura vraiment un impact ça ne va
pas tout régler évidemment mais je crois
que les effets vraiment se feront sentir
c'est aussi pour les emplois d'avenir
une façon de mettre le pied à l'étrier
des jeunes et des jeunes 16 à 25 ans qui
sont sans qualification et sans emploi
on a par exemple beaucoup moqué vous
rappeler les emplois jeunes on a
certaines personnes certains beaux
esprits mais je vous rappelle qu'une
évaluation était fait de ces emplois
jeunes qui montrent aussi tous les côtés
positifs
deux sets ce dispositif est bien avec
les emplois d'avenir nous voulons aussi
permettre à des jeunes il ya des jeunes
qui sont dans les zones urbaines
sensibles dans des endroits à des
territoires en difficulté est bien de
d'intégrer des collectivités
territoriales vrai que les effets soient
immédiat parce que la tante vous l'avez
vu même si vous prêtez assez fait
attention aux sondages en tout cas une
forte attente jean fitte malaise vous
propose de rester avec nous on va
s'intéresser à présent aux questions
d'éducation puisque l'inspecteur
d'académie de développer des yvelines
nous nous a rejoints il a tenu il ya
quelques jours on forcément pour la
rentrée une conférence de presse voici
déjà la teneur de ce qui s'est dit on va
développer tout ça en plateau avec lui
et jean philippe mallet député ps des
yvelines reste avec nous un coup de
booster c'est ainsi que jean michel
coignard directeur académique des
yvelines a qualifié hier lors d'une
conférence de presse les visites
successives dans le département ces
dernières semaines du ministre de
l'éducation nationale vincent peillon et
du président de la république françois
hollande
le directeur académique se dit plutôt
satisfait de cette rentrée même s'il
n'oublie pas l'incident d'achères la
séquestration d'une inspectrice dans une
école maternelle par des parents qui
souhaitait l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
classe ce que j'en tire pour leurs
responsabilités a progressé que si ça ne
relève pas d'une ouverture de classe
comme on en fait aujourd'hui février en
revanche effectivement j'en vois un
enseignant supplémentaire à charge pour
l'école d'organiser son activité les
prises en charge pédagogique bellec cet
enseignant de plus pas d'ouvertures de
classes officielle pour l'école
maternelle vola d'achères dans le reste
du département quatre classes ont fermé
comme à l'école élémentaire claude monet
d'elancourt
en revanche 22 classes ont été ouvertes
dans des écoles maternelles et
élémentaires à versailles bois d'arcy ou
encore magny les hameaux
selon les syndicats enseignants snes
csnu et pépé les ouvertures de classes
ne compense pas les fermetures de ces
cinq dernières années dans le
département
côté recrutement 22 nouveaux enseignants
ont été accueillis dans les yvelines
avec une problématique non résolues pour
l'instant comment garder les professeurs
sur le territoire à long terme
comme nous avons beaucoup donné aux
entrants et je m'aperçois que pour le
premier degré y compris dans les
yvelines
ces nouveaux entrants sont souvent venus
d'ailleurs sont venus de province ont
fait leurs études à paris met donc une
partie d'entre eux ne va pas se fixer
définitivement dans notre région que ce
soit particulièrement dans les yvelines
département
si bien que structurellement il faut qu
on s'accoutume au fait qu'on a un manque
ou un besoin permanent de nouveaux
personnels la solution réside peut-être
dans le développement de nouveaux
masters enseignement dans les facs du
territoire de l'académie de versailles
un projet de loi en ce sens devrait être
présenté d'ici la fin de l'année
enfin changement notable fini
l'inspection académique au chesnay les
200 employés du site déménageront à la
toussaint dans de nouveaux locaux avenue
du centre à guyancourt
ils seront sur le même site qu'une
partie des services du rectorat